e e
I am going to open the public hearing
for Senate Bill
3:15 and this is actually a non- gerain
Amendment um
we are going to uh stand for the Pledge
of Allegiance and just so everybody
knows that our chairman who is the
sponsor of both of our non-gain
amendments today is actually in the
Senate introducing an amendment that he
has there and obviously if it's in the
Senate we you know would like that to go
forward so I am going to go ahead and um
lead us in the Pledge of Allegiance and
then just so everybody knows we will be
in recess until our chairman is able to
get here from the Senate
iedge to flag of the United States of
America and to the Republic for which it
stands one nation under God indivisible
with liberty and justice for
all right we will be in recess I
would he thought he would be here very
shortly after 10 o'clock so we will just
keep our eye out for him
yeah
e
e e
ready Terry
ready okay all right welcome back
everybody I am going to reopen the
public hearing for the non- gerine
amendment to Senate Bill 315 the
amendment is
2024-25
7h and I recognize chairman Roy to
introduce his Amendment thank you madam
chairman uh members of the
committee today I'm bringing forward
Amendment 164 7h
this deals with the issue of
squatters um we had a brief conversation
about it last week and in between that
time and now we've taken steps to narrow
down this
definition and with regard to who it
applies to and who it
doesn't we wanted to be very careful to
make sure that we weren't getting
involved in landlord tenant disputes or
in any way infringing on anyone's rights
to doe process through a vict
process this is designed to deal
strictly with people that have
absolutely no business being in someone
else's home or property and who have
taken advantage of our lack laws to do
so I understand that we will probably
have to um make some changes to this as
we listen to testimony this morning this
is designed to be the beginning step and
we will continue to work on it to get it
correct before we bring it forward to
the floor but it is something that our
constituents have asked for
um I know personally I've received
numerous emails and phone calls and
there are numerous stakeholders involved
in asking us to do
something therefore I'm bringing this
forward and I ask that we work on it
together and that we take our time and
get it right but it's not something that
can be put off because it's happening to
people now thank
you representative
celik thank you and thank you for taking
my question um I'm curious see since I
live in a college town where many
students sublet their properties over
the summer and they tend not to do it
with any paperwork or any proof or
documentation of any kind so that there
are other people living in their
Apartments who are certainly not listed
in anything um how you know if if for
example um someone subl an apartment and
they believed they were doing everything
they were supposed to but the landlord
determined that they weren't on the
lease and decided they shouldn't be
there what's the protection for the
person who believed that they had an
appropriate subl with this bill well as
it's written now and as I said I'm I'm
certainly open to making tweaks to it as
it's written now the landlord first of
all would have to swear under the pains
and penalties of perjury that he had no
idea that this person is a tenant never
heard of them before they never he's
never seen them before so first of all
he's making a statement that if he
falsified he could be charged second of
all it allows for the person to produce
any kind of evidence um a bill something
with their address that shows that
they've lived there for a period of time
so it's not even Witnesses they know
she's lived with us this is about people
who have no evidence the land lord has
no idea who they are it's never seen
them
before thank you right I understand that
but often times especially what I
witness with students is they arrange a
summer sublet purely by word of mouth
with the other student who's on the
lease right so um for example you know
if if Jody was a college student in
Durham and she had an apartment and I
representative new will and I I had
arranged with her just through text
messaging or whatever I wouldn't have
any proof or documentation
representative n may not have bothered
to notify her landlord because she might
not have realized that she should tell
her landord Lord you know and and I
wouldn't have thought to tell the
landlord cuz I just thought well isn't
this just kind of how it works I'm just
staying here for a couple months in the
summer so again there wouldn't be
documentation but if the landlord then
decided to come in and found me and
viewed me as a squatter because I'm not
on the lease I'm just a friend of
Representative NES what's what's the
protection in that case with
this I would um first point to the
language currently in there that says
unrestricted um if it's a rental
property it falls into the restricted
property um so this wouldn't apply to
that if it's a if it's a rental a true
rental that's used as a rental um but I
would also say at some point we have to
to draw a line and you can come up with
as many scenarios as you want but at the
end of the day what happens if that's
someone's house so we have to be able to
balance that somehow so we can't
extend to to people that just seem to
have no way to prove that they were
there legally at all
ever so as to allow people to move into
someone's home while they're not home so
I think we have to find that
balance representative
Muse thank you for taking my question um
it's not like New Hampshire doesn't have
any protections against this at all and
uh what I'm wondering is what do you
think the problem is specifically where
with our existing civil law
that requires us to speedily take uh
this kind of an
action um actually we we have no
protections against this at all we have
a protection against adverse possession
which means I actually take your home
and it's mine now but against me while
you're on vacation moving in putting my
stuff in there and making myself a
sandwich and saying I live here now and
you come home and say he doesn't belong
here I say I do he said I could live
here you have no protection at all the
police are going to say go to court now
you may have the ability to pay for a
hotel and an attorney to have me removed
after months but say it's a family with
young children who come home from a
vacation they went on a 10-day Cruise
they saved up a year to pay for that
they've got uh a 2-year-old an
18-month-old and their seven-year-old
grandmother with them lived with them
they get home someone's in their home
they say we live here they said we could
now they have to go get a hotel get a
lawyer and wait time to get into the
courts to have someone evicted they the
money for it so why should someone who
saved their life to build a home and buy
a home be forced to be homeless while
someone else squats in their home and
our laws have no mechanism to remove
somebody immediately so in effect the
person who owns the home is now homeless
and their kids are homeless they can't
go to work because their clothes are in
there the kids can't go to school their
entire life is upside down and contrary
to popular belief I've received emails
from s people this has happened in The
Lakes area I got one and somewhere on
the coast another
one followup please follow
up so I I I do know that in New
Hampshire um you actually have to live
in a place for 20 years to be able to
claim a residency um uh short of that 20
years you're trespassing and my
understanding is there is a civil
process that uh can be undertaken
that we have used successfully in this
state for many years uh represent people
are in this
situation yeah my my qu my question uh
my question
boils down to the fact um of why is this
bill necessary at this time sure I'll
reiterate the 20-year law is for adverse
possession that means before it can
become legally yours in other words the
house is now yours not only can you stay
there it's your house after 20 years
that doesn't apply to get people out in
the meantime and to your point there is
a civil process indeed and that would
involve going to court getting on the
docket hiring an
attorney um and during that time which
can be months sometimes a year because
it's the normal eviction process the
person who owns the home the person
who's paying the taxes on the home can't
use the
home representative PR
so just for a little Clarity like in
representative s they sublet nobody
would know that they were subletting
because the real owner isn't
coming to to Mo get back in right so
nobody would know that it only happens
in like the scenario that you're talking
about they went away for a little while
the real occupants show up and then
somebody else is there that's correct so
the chances of representative s isn't
going to happen no the only way I could
potentially see what her scenario
happening is if the landlord wanted to
relet the house to someone and that
person was there and so well no I
already let it and they don't have a
lease they'd end up in a court dispute
and that's that I don't I don't see this
law applying because it's restricted
property thank
you representative
Newman yeah I just have a question on
the language on
um first page line 12 and it's just I'm
a little bit confused about what it
actually means the the language and it's
it says has caused to believe that the
person is not a legal occupant of a
non-restricted property pursuant to a
written lease or agreement or other
agreement between the person and the
owner and the design and my confusion is
does it apply to someone that has a
lease or does it only apply to people
that are unrestricted and don't have a
lease which one well the unrestricted
part refers to the category of property
whether it's a a a a lease property
that's used for rentals that falls under
our rental lease laws and the the the
lease
portion is meant to cover people who
don't have a lease because as has been
pointed out many people don't have a
written lease so it covers both whether
they have a lease or other agreement
such as a handshake that says you can
follow up follow up and we so that that
definition of unrestricted property
would be in the law that's being that
that would be amended by this yes it's
an existing statute and that language
came at the suggestion of the Attorney
General's office so as to stay out of
landlord tenant
disputes I I'm surprised personally I'm
surprised that that's not Criminal
Trespass and they're thrown out
immediately by the police but that's
that's a person might miss perhaps
misunderstanding this squatter business
if somebody is in the house when you get
home didn't they break and Enter isn't
that a crime right then and there I mean
that this is a criminal act you you
would one would think so um but first of
all um we don't have a breaking and
entering statute per se in in New
Hampshire we have a um robbery statute
that means that you illegally enter a
property with the intent to commit a
crime
and that would apply but once someone
has said I'm legally here now you have
to prove did they and it puts the police
in in a horrible situation because if
they deprive someone of their rights
because they're a tenant and you know
it's it's it it puts them in a difficult
situation so they inevitably do what
they should and say you got to go to
court with this mess um but to your
point you would think it's Prime of face
you broken in or you don't belong here
but once they say no oh I live here I'm
not committing a crime it takes it into
a whole new new
realm see no more questions thank you
very much thank
you Miss Corell
good morning uh my name is kirson
Cornell I am an attorney at New
Hampshire legal assistance I'm here
today in opposition to this amendment um
I want to make sure that everybody is
clear about a couple of things before we
get started unrestricted property under
the law um refers to um rental property
that um include that includes four units
or less where the owner is occupying one
of the units or single family homes in
which the owner owns three or fewer
properties so I honestly was having a
little bit of a hard time hearing I just
want to make sure we're clear about that
cuz I thought that I heard it
represented that uh unrestricted
property did not relate to rental
property and I want to be clear that it
is it is distinguished from restricted
property um which is all other property
but for what I just said um and the you
know basic reason behind this
distinction is to try to allow uh a
little bit more flexibility for
landlords who are who have only a few
Properties or who live in the property
that they're renting than uh those
landlords who uh it's their business of
renting housing so they have many
properties so I just want to make sure
we're clear about that um in terms of
adverse possession in order to gain any
property rights through adverse p
adverse possession which is typically uh
what is referred to you know what
squatting refers to um one has to openly
um use the property for 20 years so it's
not a matter of somebody coming and
residing in a place for a couple of
months there has to be 20 years um to
gain any property rights uh with regards
to what was stated um you know a family
goes away for 10 days comes back that is
in fact Criminal Trespass that would not
require the eviction process um in order
to remove the person um and while I am
not an expert in criminal law um I do
believe we have a burglary Statute in
the state of New Hampshire which would
be breaking and entering so uh just
wanted to to talk about those things
first um you know I I'm happy to hear
representative Roy say that um he
understands that that we need to use a
process to come to agreeable terms with
regards to um a bill that is solving a a
problem that uh I don't believe is is
new and I don't believe is
expansive um the amendment as written I
think is confusingly written um as a
lawyer I had to read it a number of
times to fully understand what it meant
um and the way that it is written it
would be enforced by police officers and
landlords who
uh while they have jobs that I imagine I
couldn't do I don't believe that they
necessarily will be able to immediately
understand the statute and they will be
the ones responsible for enforcing it
without any opportunity for um a an
occupant whether they be there lawfully
or not to be heard by a judge uh which
is the typical process for civil
matters
um which is the biggest issue I think
with this bill is that it doesn't
provide protection for people who either
are there lawfully or who believe that
they are there lawfully like in the
example of the subletting student
earlier uh the only way that that person
would be able to get a hearing in a
court would be if they uh declin to
leave when they are asked by the police
and then um were removed and were
arrested for trespass and then went to a
criminal Court to be heard on whether or
not they had committed the crime of
trespass uh housing is a civil matter
it's not a criminal matter and that's
why laws related to rental housing are
in RSA 540 or chapter instead of the um
criminal law rsas which are in chapter
600 and I'm not an expert on criminal
law so I I can't tell you exactly I
apologize for that um I can tell you
that the bill references uh 6351 and
6352 which I believe are TR I know one
is trespassing and I believe the other
is
burglary uh my what my biggest concern
with this bill is that as written I
believe that it does uh something that
people talk about a lot um but I'm not
sure is ever really defined which is
criminalizing homelessness so the
example that was given was somebody
coming home you somebody breaking into
somebody's house while they're on
vacation for 10 days um that is that is
a crime and that is trespassing but a
situation where somebody is staying in a
place where they either believe that
they are allowed to be or perhaps they
you know if we take is true that they
they know that they don't have any
specific um authorization to be there
that's a separate thing from
trespass that is not having a place to
go and and I believe everyone in this
state is aware that we're in the midst
of a crushing housing crisis in fact
we're in the midst of the most acute
housing crisis that is being experienced
across the country we had the highest
proportion increase percentage increase
of uh homelessness over between 2022 and
2023 I say all of this because I think
it's important to realize that people
are staying places where potentially
they don't have direct authorization
because they don't have anywhere to go
there's a 6% vacancy rate in the state
right now a healthy housing economy has
a 5 to 6% vacancy rate and that means
that it's a housing economy where a a
per you know a person who's renting a
home could relatively easily um you know
move from one rental to another without
losing access to their Community without
having to move across the state or even
leave the state without having to uproot
their their children from their school
and and get new doctors um you know as
we heard representative Roy say one of
person becomes homeless their life falls
apart and I think we need to be very
clear about what is happening with this
law and and what what is falling apart
due to actions that I do not believe
have Criminal Intent and intent is a
requirement in order to be convicted of
a crime um I think that there is a
willingness on the part of um I know
there's a willingness on the part of New
Hampshire Legal Assistant as well as um
landlord representative to work together
to find a solution to um the issue of
circumstances where a person is not
authorized to be in a in a building and
it and it becomes difficult for a
property owner to have them removed
through the court process but we have a
civil statute RSA 540A that provides an
opportunity for both landlords and
tenants to bring actions before the
court to say that one of the you know
the the other party is behaving
unlawfully and to ask the court for and
that does not take a long time uh so I I
just would really encourage um ask this
committee to uh think carefully about
what the full consequences are of of
this amendment uh the how it is treating
people in very vulnerable situations and
and to recognize that there is a group
of people with a lot of knowledge in
this area who are willing to work
together to come up with something that
will
work happy to take questions
so I I have a question um I'm looking
the the criminal trespass has been
mentioned so I'm looking at that
particular statute
and so I actually have so in here where
it says about was asked to be was asked
to leave or if they didn't leave and
then you had mentioned a a court order
so could you ex could you maybe touch on
that a little bit more because I think I
was a little bit confused so in this
situation if you know you come home and
there indeed is a is a person there and
you say hey this is my house leave like
what are you doing here and the cop
comes and says you have to leave and
they
won't then that's where I was confused
on what you said about about going
through court so in that instance the
person would be arrested for criminal
trespassing and they would be removed
from the property that I believe is a
different circumstance than what I
understand this bill to be trying to
address which is when a person is
inhabiting a home for a period of time
without a a rental facility a rental
home without a direct relationship or
direct agreement between that person and
the landlord which again is what we get
at in the issue of the college student
that was the example that was given
earlier where that student has not
communicated directly with the landlord
because they thought it was sorted out
with the person who was living there
previously and so they don't know that
they're there unlawfully and then
they're faced with this you know
trespassing charge in that instance when
we're talking about a person breaking
into a home and and being there while a
family's on
vacation that's a very different
situation that is CRI that is
trespassing and potentially burglar like
I said I'm not a criminal attorney so I
can't I don't want to try to speak to
that but if a person is guilty of
trespass then they will be arrested and
removed and they will have the
opportunity to be heard by the criminal
court that's a separate issue from a
housing matter that goes before a civil
court so in reference to what you had
mentioned about the college student so
if the college student is subletting
their property and their lease clearly
says that they're not to do that and
they claim what we didn't know when they
clearly signed the lease I would have to
think if they were in college it would
be literate so what is the process for
that so so I I think that we're getting
a little mixed up in the example the
example as I understood was not that
the the person who would be removed
under this statute would be the
subletter so the subletter may not have
read the lease especially a college
student I can honestly think of a time
that I sublet a unit when I don't think
I had any contact with the landlord so
in under this it would be the person who
was there the subletter who would be
removed and potentially charged with
trespassing not the person who violated
the lease provision of of not subletting
the apartment in the instance that um
there is an effort to remove the person
who was the lawful uh tenant under the
lease who was violating the no
subletting provision there is an
eviction process for a
violation a violation of substantial
violation of a lease provision that
would go through the eviction process
under RSA 540 so it's two it's two
separate issues and and under this
amendment it is the person without
knowledge who would be being removed and
potentially charged with criminal
receive criminal penalties because they
were unaware of of their law whether
their presence was allowed okay
representative PR
so let's jump right back into that so
I'm a
landlord I write
noting not student goes off
sublets and now I find out that's
happened and I want that person removed
because as a landlord I want to know
who's in my building in my apartment I
want to vet them but I didn't get to vet
them so you're going to take my rights
away as a
landlord say that I can't remove that
person that I didn't want there I'm not
saying that at all what I am saying is
that there we can create a civil process
that can be Speedy that will allow that
to occur I'm not trying to say that
that's never an issue I'm not trying to
say there aren't instances when there
are problems with tenants who or not
tenants people who are there um
unlawfully perhaps
unknowingly and we can address that
issue I don't think that this Amendment
does that appropriately and I don't
think that it will do it successfully
and I think that that there are is a
group of people who again have a lot of
expertise on these things who are
willing to work together to address the
issue you just
articulated followup
so I'm the landlord I go to the
subletter I said you need to be out get
them out that day we go through the
Civil process that takes a while they
trash my building because they know
they're getting thrown out right but if
I could have got them removed right then
that day I wouldn't have that problem I
wouldn't have all that damage so I would
say two things one you could bring a
claim against them in small claims court
uh in order to get the the cost of the
damage that occurred I would also say
that in any uh business that you conduct
there is some level of risk and that if
the person and that also that the
process doesn't have to take a long time
I think that can create a process that
is quite Speedy it may not be a removal
in a day but it can be a removal it
certainly is not the 30 30 days that uh
an eviction takes which is what happens
under RSA 540 and I think people are
referring to so doesn't this amendment
do that this amendment would uh require
somebody to leave that day or be um at
risk of being charged with trespassing
they would have no no opportunity to go
before a judge to prove that they were
there
lawfully and the law would be enforced
by um the police rather than a court um
which is where civil matters belong
under this there there's no way for a
person it was also mentioned previously
you know that the landlord would need to
swear under the penalties of perjury
that what they're saying is true um but
it would also be very difficult for a
person to bring any action if that
statement was false and by the time they
were able to bring an action they would
have lost their personal property and
they would be homeless and the redress
for that would be difficult to come by
and would take a long time what I'm
saying is
that we are not saying that that there
is never a problem but creating a a
criminal incorporating a criminal
statute into a civil law does not create
a process that truly addresses the
problem and does create a process that
places people who are there lawfully or
believe that they are there lawfully at
Great risk of losing their property of
becoming homeless and potentially having
criminal charges brought against
them wait wait representative PR I'm
going to move on and if your question
doesn't get answered we'll come back to
you representative
Newman thank you madam
chair could you kind of Cl clarify for
me when a person has a lease and then
they lose their job they they start not
paying their they fall behind on their
rent where is the the line there that
they are now illegally in the in the U
process so yeah so in the instance that
a person has a lease and they are uh
become unable to pay their rent um that
will go through the eviction process but
for a payment of rent eviction it's a
7-Day notice period and then it goes to
court so a 7-Day notice period from the
time that the person is notified that
they're being evicted to the time that
it goes through court and they you know
that that process begins is only 7 days
so then that court process goes on
there's actually um an allowance in the
law for the person to find a way to
catch up on rent within like the time
before the hearing comes in order to
maintain housed um but that would go
through uh the the eviction process
which is in RSA
540 followup
followup and the other thing that
confuses me about the the language as it
is so if you if you own the
home it's not a rental property so so
what what's the circumstance how does
this work when it's your home and
somebody's in
it how does that different from rental
from a rental property oh I want to make
sure I understand what you're saying so
are you talking so if a person has a
lease then they are renting that
property and somebody else owns it so
that could be a single family home it
could be an apartment complex it could
be a duplex for clarification I was just
thinking that that the home was owner
occupied how how is is that affected by
this at all so owner
occupied um dwellings are actually
governed under RSA 540 B and um RSA 540b
applies to instances where um an owner
rents out say one bedroom of their house
um and the process for removing a tenant
under that law is um is is different and
and doesn't have court process um there
is a a notice requirement um and the the
period of the notice requirement depends
on the uh reason for the eviction uh and
then the the person can seek the the
owner can ask the police to come and
have the person removed um the owner is
required to um maintain the property the
personal property of the person who's
been living there for a period of time
and allow them to come back and get it
so that they don't lose all of their
personal property it would note that in
those
instances we have often found that
police officers will are reluctant to
enforce 540b because they believe
housing to be a civil matter as well and
suggest that it go through the court
process unfortunately that's not a
possibility under 540b which presents a
separate legal issue but that's the
process in that circumstance can I ask
one final question just to clarify what
you said about I wanted just one more
yes but I would like to point out to the
committee that we are this bill is not
addressing people that have not paid
their rent that a landlord knows is
there this bill is
addressing people that are illegally
living or occupied a a property that
they had no right to do in the first
place and that the landlord was not
aware that was even there so we're not
talking about people that just didn't
pay their rent so just like to clarify
that and my question would be if if
there is no rental they didn't rent out
any of the property how are they
affected by this bill you come home the
cruised thing you come home there's
somebody in your house MH and you don't
rent out any rooms how how does this
Bill affect that situation um I don't
think that this bill applies to that
situation I think that situation would
be addressed criminally through a a
being charged with criminal
trespass thank
you representative Su thank you and
thank you for taking my question I'm I'm
curious too thinking about that people
sometimes have people move in with them
who wouldn't be on a Le Le for example
it might be a romantic relationship that
goes arai and sometimes becomes a
domestic violence
situation um where someone could then
say you know this person is not allowed
to live here um would would this bill
then put the victim of the domestic
violence at additional risk of being so
that trying to understand yes so the the
relation between uh a person who is a
survivor of domestic violence and is
living with the perpetrator of that
violence is a little bit complex and
Depends partially on um who is on that
lease so or one of them might be the
homeowner right so in a circumstance
where a survivor of domestic violence um
get so a survivor of domestic violence
can seek a a civil protective order
under the statute RSA
173b in that protective order they can
be granted um full access to the home
that they shared with the abuser
regardless of who owns that home or
regardless who is the renter of that
home as a protection under the DV
statute so this wouldn't apply correct
well I I I mean I think that that's
that's an open question is um we don't
fully know I don't think exactly how
everything would be swept up in this
bill I think that one of the problems
with using such an expeditious process
is that it's difficult to to think
through all of the impacts that a
proposed law may have
um it can be surprising at times to find
out the impacts that a law that has been
in place for a long time can have um and
so I think that I don't feel I can I can
fully answer that question um beyond
what I've just said and I think the fact
that I can't fully answer that question
beyond what I've just said is further
indication of the problem with trying to
rush um an amendment or a bill such as
this representative n thank you madam
chair and thank you for taking my
question sure I think um I think
actually you you kind of just hit on
what I was thinking about is the the
idea of um this being uh the difference
of between a criminal or a civil process
and how that um what that entails why it
is set up to be a civil matter and what
the implications would be of um of
essentially putting law enforcement um
in the in the position of um of of
making that decision right um and I
guess kind of you you kind of already
answered my question in saying that
there are so there are a variety of
implications coming from that um that we
can't
necessarily I'm trying to I'm trying to
get it back to a question because you
kind
aome because my question was going to be
could you speak to uh the potential
implications um that this could entail
so if you want to elaborate on that a
little bit more that would be wonderful
I'm sorry I just want to make sure I
understand so you're asking what are the
potential consequences of criminalizing
uh civil matter and involving the police
in that matter okay so I think that any
time Police become involved in a civil
matter it heightens anxiety and creates
a situation where people may behave in
ways that they ordinarily may not
especially when they feel that something
that they have a great need for is at
risk which is in this case would be
housing which is one of our most
fundamental needs shelter is one of our
most fundamental needs the other issue
so I think that it often times will
create behaviors that are escalated that
would not need be um separate and apart
from that and from a more legal
perspective it PE puts people at risk of
of being charged criminally and prot and
potentially convicted of a crime um when
they that was not their that was not
intent so for most crimes their elements
must be met and for most of them men's
rehea so intent is one of them um and in
circumstances where a person is not
intending to commit a crime but is in
fact prosecuted um and convicted of that
crime that goes on their record and then
they have a criminal record and that
makes it even more difficult to get
housing in the future to get any number
of things in the future makes it
particularly difficult if a person is
seeking some kind of rental subsidy um
which often are the very people who are
living in situations um where
potentially they don't have a direct
agreement with the landlord to stay
because they don't have anywhere to
go representative Newman yes thank you
in your capacity for dealing with all of
this in your experience have you seen an
assortment of lease is themselves and I
I would expect that some are much better
written than others yeah I've I've been
practicing housing law for seven years
um I've seen quite a few leases um it is
absolutely true that some are I I don't
know if it's better or worse some are
written with many more terms than others
some are written with much more clear
Provisions than others um some are not
written right so there are lease there
there are tency agreements that are oral
but there are many things that a
landlord could write into a lease that
would accomplish the objectives that it
seems this is this is trying to
yes Qui just a quick followup
um this is a question poorly
phrased in in the leases I'm familiar
with I don't know if it's still current
or not but the former real um the
Realtors had a standard lease agreement
that would be used and I believe
in there it was addressed number of
occupants you had the name so the
landlord could vet the people coming in
I believe there were also Provisions for
guests how long they could stay and
there probably was something in there
about no subletting in in there would
would that be something yes I would say
that the large majority of leases that I
see have no subletting Provisions um and
what you've described is accurate I
think that the one exception for when
names may not be on a lease is sometimes
children are not named on leases so they
may have the number of children and the
ages of the children but not the names
of
children representative
scitec um uh Madam chair do you know
where this bill is going is there going
to be a subcommittee committee the whole
what's going to happen to this um I do
not know the answer to that question at
this time represent I have about 30 to
40 questions all right well that's a
good place to keep them thank you very
much thank
you I have a
question
yes I think we are
okay thank you very much for the
opportunity to speak my name is Nick
Norman I'm a advocate for housing
providers I was here last week I am a
government Affairs chair for Association
the apartment association of New
Hampshire and also the rental Property
Owners
Association been involved in advocating
for housing providers for about 13 years
um very experienced with this
uh myself I have 48 units I've been in
Property
Management uh landling you could say for
about 35 years we've been very active
and my core team on this
particular issue I sent an email to you
previously last week and I sent one very
early in the morning when I was finally
getting through with you know pulling
all together the pieces so you have that
there's been even yet some some
additional changes which I'm going to
pass out to you in my proposed amendment
I have been talking with Elliot Barry
and Kristen of the New Hampshire legal
assistance we're prepared to present to
you um some ideas that will make this
work in a way that um well it could make
it work so I'm going to pass that out to
you when I I finish I invite questions
particularly many questions this is a
very complex issue anytime you start to
work with changing landlord tenant law
and real estate law is complex there's
many many scenarios you've heard many
different scenarios that have come up so
when you're putting together a law you
need to make sure that you're addressing
all those different scenarios and you're
doing in responsible way that doesn't
have tremendous unint unintended
consequences so first the bill the
amendment as it's written has some
several major
concerns uh first of all it's good that
we're addressing squatting that's an
issue we need to address it it happens
for people that own their homes and are
not renting it happens for people that
are owning property and they're renting
it out so we do need to address
that um the
some of the concerns are that there's in
this bill solicited some proofs of what
would conate a proof of a residence but
uh most many of those could easily be
falsified utility bills for instance I
have a tenant move into a property
routinely practically every time and
they turn on the utilities without ever
Consulting me the utility company just
turns them on so having a proof of
service like that would would be uh I
would I would say not sufficient to
prove
residency same with there's a language
in there that says other services but
it's not defined what is another service
a laundry
service um also is listed as approve
government
ID but it's not defined what kind of ID
does it actually specify an address and
we know that government IDs can be
falsified so I think that those are not
good
uh sufficient
proofs uh it shouldn't be that the
housing provider is at risk of someone
squatting because a utility company or a
government ID or some other service has
a
loose uh requirement for establishing
the
service uh I also think it would be a
mistake for the legislature to get too
heavily involved in
defining the various proofs that that
really should be something in the the
court I also think that in general we
should get rid of the idea there seems
to be a presumption that someone
occupying a property has to go through
the eviction
process um I think there should be some
due
process um and one of the things that
was mentioned is about sheriffs and
police police in particular I can tell
you from the years of experience that
that I have and the the uh input that I
get from our members we distribute
legislative updates to about
3500 recipients around the state of New
Hampshire landlords across the entire
state every week um police typically
will not get involved in removing
someone that's illegally in an
apartment you go to them and say that
here's proof that they're not legally
able to or should be there the police
typically won't touch it they say I'm
sorry that's a civil matter even though
perhaps it does look like they're
trespassing so then when you get into
that situation they'll say you need to
go evict them someone asked about the
length of the eviction
process that I can review my notes right
here I can tell you about the eviction
process it can
take typically about six to eight weeks
to get someone out on the shortest um
eviction process with other Provisions
in the law can take up to 169 days with
appeals it can be a year or longer so I
mean just it's just un tenable to to go
through eviction process for someone
that has no right to be there
however as much as Property Owners would
like to see in a quick and judic and
expedient process to get a squatter out
it would be against the
Constitution of the United States 5ifth
and 14th amendments to deny someone due
process or something that removes their
deprives them of life liberty and
property
and so you have to have some kind of a
due process now we can make that due
process very expedient and that is what
Chris
has just referred to and Elliot and I
are working together in in my proposal
that I'll give to you there's a process
that's Loosely called the 540A petition
in landlord tenant law it's already
written in the law it has a very large
amount of vetting for years and years to
create a a good
process and it can be expedient and
quick in our propos proposal we would
make it two
days to go through the process and I
believe we've already talked quite a bit
that we can come together with something
for you on that and I'll be here this
afternoon during your exact
session there's some other issues with
the bill as written I can go into more
but what I'd like to do at the risk of
taking too much time is go ahead and
pass out
this amendment uh not Amendment but
proposal and um we can talk about that
shortly okay just so the just so the
committee is aware this I believe this
is an amendment that's being passed out
that has not yet been introduced so we
will not be discussing any part of this
amendment right
now okay this is I wouldn't even say
it's a Amendment it's a proposal of what
could be done to address this situation
give due process make it quick and
answer pres most of the questions that
have been raised here
I'm
headed
requested
e
e e
we are I am um
reopening our public hearing and just
for
everybody's you know thought or
consideration um I feel like we're kind
of gone down a different path of what
the bill is that we're addressing we are
not here addressing a person that is not
paying rent right we're not here talking
about um any kind of rental property
we're talking about people that have
taken possession of
property without a lease with without a
verbal contract of you know you may live
here um so let's just please keep that
in mind as we as we continue this um
and I'm not really sure what this
particular P papers okay so you may
continue thank you so the
amendment 1647 H as written does address
rental
property that's very clear it talks
about
about non-restricted
property and non-restricted property
does include rental
property um so what we're
proposing is we use a process that's
already in place called The
540A petition and the short version of
that would be that the housing provider
files a petition that says the occupants
are there without
permission and that could be uh a
homeowner that just owns their home and
doesn't lease it it could be a landlord
either
one uh stating that the the ents don't
have any right there the arents would
then need to show evidence like a lease
or rental payments or other evidence to
prove their residency or owner interest
a hearing would be held with in 48
business hours the court would rule if
the rule if the Court ruled in favor of
the owner then the people would be
removed uh immediately by law
enforcement if the ruling was in favor
of the occupants then they would stay
and if the owner wanted to pursue
further they' have to go through the
normal eviction process so it would
provide means of due
process and it would provide something
very
expeditious with the backing of laws
already in
place I would love to take any
questions and I will be here in
between now and your exec session I'll
plan to be at the exec session and be
available for questions as well New
Hampshire legal assistance and my
organization
are are ready to work on this and put
something together that will work for
all
situations so please keep in mind we are
not asking questions on the paper that
was just handed out this is not language
that has been
introduced do you still have a question
representative
Muse yes thank you for letting me uh
thank you for letting me ask
it
uh one of the things that you you seem
to be saying uh in your testimony is
that we we should really be looking at
creating a FastTrack process within
existing to creating a separate uh
criminal process is that kind of a short
way to describe what what you're
suggesting yes okay yeah thank
you I have a point of order yes
representative the point of order is you
you you say this is an amendment it's
not an amendment it's testimony from the
person here and it gives information on
what it has I have questions about do
process and I look at this and there is
one section of it that gives a a a valid
way to make this bill bet make this
amendment better to have it done in one
or two days and I think that we probably
have the right to ask questions about
testimony so I want to leave it at that
thank you very much
okay anybody
else thank you very much sir
Mr B Mr
Barry thank you madam chairman or act
Madam acting chairman I suppose wor um
for the record my name is Elliot Barry
i' I too had the opportunity to testify
before you last time just to remind you
or for people who haven't uh who weren't
here uh uh I have represented tenants in
at at New Hampshire legal assistance for
47 years before my retirement um I'm not
going to repeat a lot of what my former
colleague Kirsten Cornell testified to I
just want to emphasize that what the
bill does and my major problem problem
with it is two things number one it
makes the police the judge in the case
rather than a
judge number two the only way that the
tenant or the alleged tenant gets to
tell his or her side to to of the story
to a neutral decision maker is in
defending a criminal
prosecution even if he or she is willing
to take that chance and many won't be
even if they do many applications for
whether it's tency or a job will ask
have you ever been
arrested what's the answer and they
could have had a very legitimate claim
to be where they
are most importantly I want to say that
I very much agree with Nick Norman there
is an existing statute RSA
54a which I have been involved with
hundreds of times that provides a very
almost most immediate access for the off
offending party the plaintiff to get
before the court and get an immediate or
temporary order which is followed up by
a final order and is enforceable by
contempt of the powers of contempt of
court that is 540A I don't need I drew
up an amendment and this is really
interesting I mean obviously I'm not
legislative Services I have it if you
want it but remarkable thing about it is
that acting
independently my version is quite
similar to what Nick Norman did using
the existing process with the only
possibility of criminal prosecution
would be contempt of court if after a
hearing the So-Cal the alleged tenant
refuses to comply with the legitimate
order of the
Court um
oh just one other thing the scenario
where you go on vacation you come home
to your house and somebody is living in
there if that isn't Criminal Trespass I
don't know what is and I agree with Nick
that there are plenty of fuzzy cases
espe in the apartment context where the
police may say this looks kind of more
appropriate for eviction than it does
for Criminal Trespass
but I cannot believe that there are is
any significant number of cases where
the police have refused to remove
somebody from a single family home when
it you know returning from a vacation um
that's my testimony I'd be happy to
answer any questions but if you give us
the time and that we don't need a lot of
time I am very confident that Mr Norman
and the landlords he represents and Miss
Cornell and New Hampshire legal
assistance and I can work out something
that will make a civil a fair civil
process that's fast and comports with
due
process thank you madam chair um the
information that you have did you make
copies of it yeah I have it like are you
going to pass that out for if you like
thank you I don't want to swamp you with
papers especially it's not but again I
understand it's not an amendment it's
something to think about if you were you
gave 247 thank you madam
chair excuse me oh he's passing oh
wait so does your proposed
information uh have an immediate
relief um what the way I've written it
and it's subject to negotiation the the
land the owner of the property would
provide a a notice saying get out in 3
days uh and if they don't uh if they
either leave or then the landlord files
a petition in which an order could be
granted that day a temporary order and
that would and the Tenant would have a
right to a hearing within 48 working
days again which is interesting because
Mr Norman and I that provision about a
40 a hearing within 48 days of filing
the request for a hearing uh is is the
same hours I'm yeah sorry about that 48
Hours follow
up so in this scenario right I I have a
three story tenament my middle
apartment's
vacant I I bet somebody they go to move
in somebody's already
there can they be removed when I call
the police in your
language I think they could be if the
police will enforce as I think they
probably should Criminal Trespass then
they're out in my language um they would
have to get some notice to leave and
then uh request a hearing to court if
they don't want to go but I don't see
how you can make the
police if they're not willing to there
must be some reason the police aren't
going to enforce it and if there's not I
don't see how you can make in accordance
with the process how you can can make
the police the
judge it just doesn't make any
sense I think the confusion that we're
having is because the the due process is
the word that keeps on being said and
when the bill was introduced by the
sponsor he's not he's not talking about
people that have a legal right to be
there so I think that's where the where
we're being confused is saying well you
can follow a petition but if the person
isn't has no legal basis to be there and
now
the person that legally owns the home
has to go through a a court process I I
actually the yeah a couple things number
one the question is who has a legal
right to be here last time the owner of
the property I would have to say well
here but here's the problem I talked a
lot last time about the the issue of um
implied tencies right where a tenant has
been there with the no with the
knowledge or Ann M that that tenant had
a right to be there even though they're
not on the lease there are many and then
number of tenants have no lease and then
they're arguing about is there an oral
agreement these are legitimate things
that come up often and there's a
disagreement whether there's a
legitimate or not legitimate tency and
somebody besides the police should have
to figure that out but if we can get
them a hearing within you know within 40
48 Hours of the time the tenant asked
for it
it seems to me then at least a judge is
making the decision about whether they
do have a legal right to be there if
it's Crystal Clear they don't the police
ought to be enforcing the criminal uh
trespass statute which I have somewhere
here which couldn't be
clear oh I'm sorry here it is a person
is guilty of Criminal Trespass if
knowing that he's not licensed or
privileged to do so he enters or remains
in any place I mean if the police are
screwing this up then that's another
issue but people ought to have the right
to have some
judicial referee or judge decide whether
their claim of lawful residence is in
fact
valid representative Manion I got you
you're all set representative
Newman it seems to me the big problem in
this is in the first sentence that's in
this
bill and it says any person who has
entered or remained in an OCC within an
occupied structure or structure or
secured premises in violation of the two
laws and who law a law enforcement has
probable cause to believe is not a legal
occupant so that's where it starts to be
a judge so could you the first part of
that any person who has enter to remain
is that legal or unlegal or I'm just
confused by that entire High sentence
could you comment on that
sentence well I think there is a
legitimate uh use of the word have they
entered and remained an occupied or
secured premises in violation of the of
the criminal law stat of the Criminal
Trespass statute that's a legitimate
sentence right but let let me just point
this out the notion of what is probable
cause probable cause is all know is is
the basis for filing a criminal
complaint it's not the basis for
deciding that somebody is acting without
right and then incarcerating them
finding them or in this case kicking
them out of their place that probable
cause is the beginning of a pro of a
legal process that has a legal hearing
attached to it and this doesn't do that
but I'm sorry I suspected by your I'm
not answering your question
it was probably a poorly worded question
representative scitech well here's
another poorly worded question you're
distinguishing the case I I have an
department for rent I haven't been there
for a few days I'm going to show a
tenant I go in and there's a guy with a
backpack and his girlfriend in there
that you're not going that P does that
person have any that's criminal
trespasses I agree okay I just want to
clear I'm looking for an egregious F
thanks no more questions thank you very
much thank
you and needless to say I'm happy to
work if you can get more time I'm happy
to work with Mr Norman and any of you to
work out a civil process to make this
okay Senator
Chanley she
gone
she I think is Miss maragold did I
pronounce that properly did I Slaughter
it what that
look thank you madam chair members of
the committee for the record my name is
Alyssa margolin baric gold is lovely um
but wow my apologies I really thought
that said that um that's okay Carry On
um I I serve as director of housing
action New Hampshire we're a Statewide
coalition of 80 organizations United to
improve state and federal policy so
everyone in New Hampshire has a place to
call home um we also wanted to raise uh
some concerns we're really pleased to
hear that the um that the uh Prime
sponsor of the non- gerain amendment has
said that he really wanted to work to
make sure he could get it right and
we're also really pleased to uh to hear
that there are proposals in play uh that
could really solve the issue uh of
concern um so we uh you know urge a
member uh of this committee to um to
work with with those experts uh to to
bring forth a uh a new formal Amendment
uh in partnership with this uh sponsor
uh to make sure but I just wanted to add
from our perspective our members are
those who develop Finance manage
affordable housing properties homeless
service providers public housing
agencies Supportive Housing providers
and low-income family advocates so we
are heavily involved in the supply side
crisis and as you know there are over 50
bills uh this session um looking at the
uh affordable housing crisis that we
have in the granite state and as Miss
Cornell said you know we have this
vacancy rate that's really concerning
really driving prices up and we have uh
a major increase in homelessness what
we're concerned with the the uh
Amendment as proposed is really the
ambiguity that's been named several
times in different ways um and also the
unintended consequences um homelessness
in our state uh can look a little
different uh particularly in places that
don't have Services close by and so a
lot of families with children will
choose to couch surf uh instead of um
seek shelter
Services um and so we're concerned that
they would get caught up in a uh
scenario that has been articulated in
this case sometimes about a student
unknowingly subletting perhaps a family
member um uh uh who is sharing uh a um
non-restricted property or even a a
rental situation and anyway it seems
like there is a a way to address any
concerns about that through a civil
process and to avoid uh putting these
families through a criminal process um
in an already uh very hostile sit
housing situation with that I really
don't have anything else to add I'm I'm
happy to feel any
questions thank you thank you very much
is there anybody else wishing to testify
on this bill that has not done so seeing
none I will close the public hearing for
the non- gerine
amendment what was it uh 20241
647h and um we are late for our other
hearing but does the committee wish to
take a few minute bio
break yes yes okay we will be um we will
be in recess until
11:40 go
quick
EXC
e
e e
good almost afternoon um we are are
going to open up the public hearing for
the non gerine Amendment
16458 and I recognize chairman Roy to
introduce his nerain Amendment thank you
madam chairman members of the committee
I'm here introducing amendment number
H this amendment provides officials with
an objetive definition of contemporary
anti-semitism needed to ensure the
proper assessment of criminal and
discriminatory incidents motivated by
anti-Semitism this bill does not create
a new law or a protected class it
implements an objective definition of
contemporary
anti-Semitism in order to clarify the
application of already existing law
protecting against unlawful conduct it
also ensures that incidents of
anti-Semitic hate and bias are treated
equally under the law and it provides
officials and institutions with proper
definitions tools for assessing the
intent of persons who engage in unlawful
activity and ensures that the public
institutions remain in compliance with
federal civil rights
obligations you guys all
set ensures that the public institutions
remain in compliance with federal civil
rights obligations promotes better bias
crime reporting and tracking which is
something we've discussed recently in
this
committee data shows that although Jews
make up less than 2% of the American
population they are amongst the most
likely of all minority groups to be
victimized by inance of hate in the
three months between October 7th 2023
and January 7th 2024 there were an
average of nearly 34 anti anti-semitic
incidents per day in the United
States these
3,291 anti-s incidents include 56
incidents of physical assault 554
incidents of vandalism
1,347 incidents of verbal or written
harassment 137 rallies that included
anti-semitic rhetoric and expressions of
support for terrorism against the state
of Israel and or Jews
generally perpetrators of law unlawful
acts of anti-Semitic crime and
discrimination often tried to escape
culpability by claiming that they are
perpetrate but they were merely
expressing anti-israel sentiment by
attacking Jewish institutions
individuals or points of Jewish
Collective
identity incid incidents of anti-Semitic
crime and discrimination risk going
unaddressed and under reported unless a
definition is adopted that identifies
the ways in which Jews are targeted by
contemporary
anti-Semitism the government has a
responsibility to protect citizens from
hate and bigotry
authorities must be given the
definitional tools needed to stem
criminal conduct and discriminatory
Behavior motivated by
anti-Semitism valid monitoring and
enforcement informed analysis and
investigating and effective policymaking
start with uniform
decisions this bill codifies the
international Holocaust remembrance
alliance definition of anti-semitism
that was made on May 26
2016 over 1100 governments Nos and other
key institutions have specifically
adopted this
definition the definition is now the
Jewish community's consensus
International standard because it can be
utilized by objectively assessing some
of the most common contemporary forms of
anti-Semitism this bill protects Free
Speech rights the bill only addresses
crime and illegal discrimination which
are not speech and are not protected by
the First Amendment this bill does not
penalize or restrict anyone's right to
freely Express anything it explicitly
says that nothing contained in this bill
is to be construed to diminish or
infringe upon any right protected made
under the First Amendment to the United
States
Constitution criticism of Israel is not
anti-semitic and the bill does not
create a speech code the definition
explicitly recognizes that it is not
anti-semitic to criticize Israel when
the same standards are applied to all
countries the definition provides
Clarity on when anti-israel speech can
cross a line into
anti-Semitism that should be taken into
account when EV valuing possible
anti-semitic intent of related crimes or
unlawful
discrimination this bill adopts a static
definition as of a set date to ensure
that the full recognized definition of
what is actually adopted and
utilized this reduces the likelihood
that the definition will be improperly
modified this bill enjoys broad
bipartisan
support support for codifying this
definition of anti-semitism is
nonpartisan and has broad Grassroots
support the anti-Semitism awareness act
adopted adopting this definition passed
the US Senate by unanimous consent in
2023 four consecutive us administrations
have utilized this definition
and today it is used by every Federal
agency the definition has been codified
and endorsed by 33 other
states I think that pretty much covers
everything and I'd be happy to take
questions representative
wheeler thank you madam chair thank you
Mr chair for taking my question I heard
this in your testimony and I see it in
the bill but I just wanted to reinforce
that this doesn't construe anti-Semitism
as criticism for Israel or vice vers
no explicit explicitly prohibit
such I would I would add to that by
saying the same way that if you were
have criticized a Vatican doesn't mean
that you're criticizing me as a
Catholic representative n thank you
madam chair thank you for taking my
question so um when you were listing out
um the instances that we have of um
assault and um uh crimes that are uh
through this definition and you
mentioned the protests I I you know I
think we're all aware that there are a
lot of protests and and unfortunately
there are um some people within those
protests who who say these when you uh
list that number are you uh holding it
up to this standard of this definition
of of um what constitutes an
anti-semitic act yes and um I would also
add that the protests that are listed
between those states don't Encompass the
prot protests that have been occurring
recently these are protests from last
year that we're talking about when of
the statistics for I'm sorry I must yeah
sure I'll read that again the date of
the protests I mean the date of the
incidents right um between October 7th
23 and January 7th 2024 okay thank you
so that's just those three months
gotta see no more questions thank you
very much thank you
is there anybody here that wishes to
testify on this
uh Amendment 20241 1645
H um for the record my name is Lauren
selig and I represent straford district
10 which is the town of Durham um and as
one of the few member Jewish members of
of the house who has directly faced um
anti-Semitism um on multiple occasions
including in response to my uh my
legislation around the concept of having
a study committee to look at hate crimes
um and having received
um uh emails and um messages of one kind
and another that attacked me purely
because of my Jewish identity and
accused me um of trying to take over the
government with my uh anti-American
beliefs because I'm a rabid such and
such and other types of words um I just
wanted to offer my services to answer
questions about um what anti-Semitism
feels like or what anti-Semitism
experiences have been um because I know
not everyone has been has had the
experience of being dis specifically
discriminated against because purely
because of their identity um I I I
consider myself very lucky to have been
born a US citizen and to have the
Privileges of a US citizen I consider
myself very lucky to have been afforded
a number of privileges in my life um
including Financial Security um but I I
can tell you that my first experiences
my first remembered experiences of
anti-Semitism began when I was a
preschooler and continued from there and
I'm more than happy to answer any
questions
representative
Muse thank you for taking my question
have you had uh a chance to look at the
IH uh definition of anti-semitism and
what are your comments on it yes I I did
in fact um pull up the specific
definition to read through it carefully
um overall I think it's a pretty strong
definition that gives clear terms I
think if you look on their website they
give specific examples of how it has
been interpreted um I think especially
in light of current events there's a
little bit of a Sticky Wicket in terms
of descriptions about Israel and the
right of Israel to exist
um and I I don't know how we address
that as a committee it's a very um
complex and complicated question that
you know has roots that are 2,000 years
old um but more specifically in the last
40 years um you know I think there's a
lot of rhetoric that's thrown around
about Israel in
particular that is based on
misinformation and
misunderstanding um and I think that
people perhaps don't understand that by
using terms like I heard on the radio
this morning where people were shouting
long live the antifa which is a Hamas
code word for kill the Jews um that
that's
what they're saying um that's not to say
I agree with the Israeli government and
how they're choosing to respond to
attacks from Hamas but um it is
certainly different when there's a
government with a specific religious
Focus although I would say that the
Israeli government is made up of people
of many
religions representative wheer thank you
madam chair does the legislation ban the
use of the word intifa as far as I
understand you know that can be used in
many different ways but it simply means
revolution I suppose um so how how it's
used is how is is is I I would say the
intent is for me the the issue and um
that's a separate but that's a separate
conversation I don't believe this bill
addresses that specifically I think
there's a lot of misunderstanding of
terms
good all right thank you for your
testimony is there anybody else here
that wishes to testify that has not
turned in a card seeing none I will
close the public hearing for the am
Amendment 202
41645 and uh the committee will be in
recess we have exec session at
1:00
e
e e
okay we're we're scheduled to
um exec this
afternoon um so the first one would be
um sp sp 315 with regard
to the tenant squatting issue I'm going
to recess that to next Wednesday and
we're going to have a a full committee
work
session um so I guess it will be called
further executive session um so that'll
be next Wednesday the that will be
coming out probably next Wednesday at
10:00 so with that I recess to
Wednesday and then we are scheduled to
exec
s508 I'm going to go a little bit off
script here because we had some people
that wish to testify and based on
confusion on the notice they thought the
hearing was at 1:00 so I'm going to
reopen the public hearing to allow some
testimony limited testimony and then
we'll be executing it right after that
has everyone pulled out a pink card that
wishes to
testify Karen can you grab those cards
and hand them to me oh no mind Paul's
getting second I'm helping get ready for
okay so we're going to hear a little bit
of thank you Paul a little testimony
before we begin from four
folks with that I reopen the public
earring
and
um I'm going to
recognize the honorable Paul
Burch Mr chair and members of this
committee it's a true and deep pleasure
to be here to see so many former
colleagues from both sides of the aisle
I was going to give out a shout out to
representative janen but I only saw him
in the uh in the uh hallway my name is
Paul Burch I live in West Milan New
Hampshire I served in the house from
2012 to 2022 and was a member of House
Judiciary Committee the entire time
I would note that I'm past president of
the bror area Jewish Community the
largest synagogue in southern Vermont
I've been described as a leading
spokesperson against anti-Semitism in
New Hampshire and elsewhere I am here to
support and urge the passage of this
amendment relating to the definition of
anti-semitism and its use in New
Hampshire's anti-discrimination laws
this should be a bipartisan measure and
I expect that it will be this amendment
is carefully and narrowly drawn I
support the amendment 100% why does New
Hampshire need the IH working definition
of
anti-semitism simply to fight hate you
must be able to identify it the IH
definition does exactly that supported
by most Jewish communities and
organizations it has been adopted by
governments businesses Nos and other
institutions around the world it is by
far the most widely accepted definition
of
anti-semitism adopted by over 1100
Global entities as of December
2022 identifying hate can have a
subjective and objective approach let's
use an example somebody wears a clan
outfit to rep's Hall and is called out
for racism they say that in their mind
there's nothing racist about a clothing
Choice similarly a call from someone
that people of color should be sent back
to where they came from insist that
racism has nothing to do it's just an
opinion so obviously leaving it to the
individual doesn't work some believe
especially on my side of the aisle that
is the exclusive right of the community
affected to Define what is racism and
hate that works in my opinion to a
limited degree what has happened in the
Jew hate universe is that in this form
of hate everybody including the Jew
haters believe they have a right to
Define what is anti-Semitic so in 2016
there was an international effort to
provide an objective working definition
of
anti-semitism which has resulted in a
working definition that has been pretty
much universally adopted in the
westernized world I can't speak to
Russia China places like
that the IH a definition consists of two
part the first part has the definition
anti-Semitism is certain perception of
Jews which may be expressed as hatred
towards Jews rhetorical and physical
manifestations of
anti-Semitism are directed towards
Jewish or non-jewish individuals and or
their property towards Jewish Community
institutions and religious facilities
the second part lists several examples
they serve as illustrations and help
with the application of the definition
in practice widespread acceptance and
use of this definition ensure that
anti-semitic incidents can be registered
and compared in a uniform and systemic
way let me emphasize that last sentence
the adoption of the working definition
ensures accurate record keeping as well
as consistent application of responses
to anti-semitic instances if you for
example
want to compare the incidence of
anti-Semitism in New Hampshire to
Georgia it helps to be using the same
definition of
anti-semitism or else you run the risk
of comparing apples to oranges and the
like so to the extent that there's a
uniformity of definition you're be
you're able to track anti-Semitism
better you're able to create data you're
able to take action on information
that's reliable
this amendment is carefully and narrowly
drawn in terms of its usage there are
limits to the legislation to prevent
misuse in terms of its application yet
if we wish our anti-discrimination laws
to be fully
applicable they must clearly be
protective of our New Hampshire Jewish
Community as well as other marginalized
groups I urge your unanimous support for
this important legislation and I thank
you
thank you for your
testimony chair calls Allison
girton Mr chair members of the committee
my name is Allison gon I am the
executive director for the Jewish
Federation of New Hampshire the only
Statewide Jewish organiz ation part of
our mission is to advocate for the
interests of the 10,000 Jewish community
members in our state to enable a
thriving and safe Jewish New Hampshire I
was also born and raised in Manchester
and currently live in B where I'm
choosing to raise my own family I'm here
today to support the international
remembrance alliance's definition of
anti-semitism and its use in New
Hampshire's anti-discrimination laws
last month the Anti-Defamation League
reported anti-semitic incidences more
than doubled in New Hampshire in
2023 since just September our
organization has received reports of
anti-Semitic vandalism images harassment
and threats in towns and schools
throughout New Hampshire including
Lancaster lonia Manchester Dublin
Portsmouth and more adults students
Jewish institutions private homes and
public spaces have all been victims how
can we fight anti-Semitism without being
able to Define it throughout our state
the Jewish Community would Define their
Judaism in many ways some would say
religious others cultural or ethnic
without a standard definition it is too
easy for people to claim something was
not anti-semitic because it was not
based on a particular characteristic
without a definition how can we expect
public officials who may not be familiar
with anti-Semitism to recognize an
incident and handle it
appropriately Sunday evening begins yum
hasawa Holocaust Remembrance Day between
Sunday evening and Tuesday evening
programs will be happening throughout
the state shocking statistics show that
46% of Young Americans 18 to 29 don't
believe denying the Holocaust is
anti-Semitic and one in five think it is
a myth Sunday afternoon over 30
community members will be peacefully
walking from Temple temp Israel in
Manchester to Temple doth yuran with the
goal of achieving 6 million steps to
remember the 6 million lives taken
during the Holocaust for the first time
I will be bringing my 11-year-old son
not only because it is important for him
to know the history of the Holocaust the
horror of what took place in honor the
lives lost but because he also needs to
know the reality of what Jewish people
are currently facing and that unless
people are willing to stand up and speak
out history will repeat itself the
statistics above show how little
knowledge young adults have and will
only allow anti-Semitism to continue to
rise it is vital that New Hampshire
clearly identifies defines anti-Semitism
to keep our Jewish communi safe amidst
the increase of threats and attacks they
face over a thousand entities have
already adopted or endorsed the
definition worldwide the IH definition
is the only definition that has been
officially recognized internationally
and adopted by mainstream Jewish
organizations
it is the most comprehensive and
effective definition of anti-semitism
ensuring proper assessment valid
monitoring compliance ensuring
anti-semitic hate and bias are addressed
and equally to other types of hate and
bias and signifies anti-Semitism will
not be tolerated in New Hampshire I ask
for your support for this important
legislation thank you thank you
is there a a a Jay Gray here no that's
you um Jay Gray we have a card for said
election law I think they maybe realized
they were in the wrong room okay Mr
Bennett good afternoon Mr chairman
members of the committee uh first off I
want to thank you for uh for for
bringing this bill we're living through
a crisis right now and um 35 states have
adopted or uh codified or endorsed this
definition over the last couple of years
and I look forward to New Hampshire
being the next one I really appreciate
um I really appreciate this this gesture
and this move because it's it's
meaningful
um one of the members U of the house you
identify yourself I'm sorry Jake Bennett
from Israeli American Coalition for
Action um a National Organization that
um that serves Jewish Americans
um so someone asked me to address the
question of uh freedom of speech and and
does defining
anti-Semitism infringe on that in some
way this bill is very clearly written to
not do that the Supreme Court has shown
uh in in a number of cases that defining
racism or bigotry does not chill the
speech of bigotry or racism this bill
likewise does not chill that speech the
purpose of having a definition is so
that when uh unlawful discrimination
happens that might might be anti-semitic
in nature but there might be confusion
what is it you know it can take so many
shapes uh anti-jewish racism conspiracy
theories um religious-based
anti-Semitism this definition helps
break it down national origin uh based
on someone's uh national origin
connection to Israel or support for
Israel so that's what this definition
does a person can still go down the
street saying whatever hateful things
they want about the Jewish people the
Jewish religion the state of Israel that
is not illegal this bill doesn't
criminalized speech but if that person
then um then unlawfully discriminates
against a Jewish New Hampshire right and
the court say I'm confused by what's
going on well here's a here's a
definition you can reference um so uh it
also will help the state be in line with
federal law because right now this
definition is being used for title six
um and there are currently bills in
Congress uh to bring it also to title 7
um through executive order um back in
September it was applied to uh to all
the the federal departments that didn't
yet use this definition um it's been
applied by the last four administrations
successively in into different uh
different departments uh President Obama
brought it into Department of State um
president Trump into Department of
Education and then President Biden into
several other departments
um so just to take a another minute to
talk about the crisis that's going on
around the country and to and to put it
in
perspective um how deep and wide is this
crisis Congress and the White House are
um are beginning to talk about uh about
applying title six penalties to schools
who are not standing up to civil rights
infringements targeting Jews uh the
gaslighting that's been happening on
campuses has been called out in
Congressional hearings uh ivy league
College presidents have been reprimanded
in those hearings um and in the national
press for sweeping the problem under the
rug for so long for pretending that
calls for genocide of Jews uh whether in
Israel or globalizing the inata that
those are not
anti-semitic it should be noted that the
word inata has a meaning it means
violent attacks and lynchings of Jewish
people and in uh in in Israel there have
been over 1500 Jews lynched uh through
mob violence or or killed in Terror
attacks under inata so on campuses here
we have students calling to globalize
the inata localize the inata um
commentators on national news outlets
are calling out the double standards
evident in the non-application of Campus
codes of conduct when it comes to
anti-Semitism we know that no school
would allow protests on campus uh to
persist for more than a day that called
for the lynching of black or lgbtq
students yet those protest test have
been going on calling for lynching of
Jews for more than 7 months since
October 7th um at the start of the
Passover holiday last week the president
of Columbia University sent out an email
to all students uh telling Jewish
students they should remain home or
could remain home for the rest of the
semester because uh because it was
dangerous for them on campus and the
school wasn't uh taking action and
actually last night they did uh and
arrested a number of the protesters um
it turned out that many of them were not
even students they were organized uh
paid protesters from
outside a couple of days ago girl at
Yale a student at Yale was stabbed in
the eye by a flag pole of one of these
protesters holding a Palestinian flag
stabbed her in the eye she's in the
hospital being treated uh another
gentleman walked through the QI New York
campus with an American flag and he was
punched and headbutted and thrown down a
flight of stairs um the examples go on
in the 3 months uh that I data for
between October 7th and January 7th
there were an average of 34 anti-semitic
incidents per day across the country
these 3,291 incidents included 56
incidents of physical assault 554
incidents of vandalism
1,347 incidents of verbal or written
harassment and 1,37 rallies that
included both anti-semitic rhetoric and
expressions of support for terrorism
against the state of Israel Andor Jews
generally
so I want to wrap up because I don't
want to I don't want to take too much
longer but this is what we're dealing
with um is uh is a a broad and
widespread crisis that is that is uh
frankly affecting not only not only
students at at college campuses but also
uh my organization uh we take complaints
from from parents and of students in
high schools and middle schools and even
elementary schools where where this
stuff is creeping in
we got a national problem and and uh I
want to thank you again for for dealing
with it because you can't treat a
problem or solve a problem if you don't
Define the problem and I'm available for
any questions and I have a onepage or
fact sheet I can hand out if the
chairman wishes sure that's fine um
representative
rhs thank you Mr chairman and thank you
for taking my question if if you don't
mind we we received um a letter in
opposition from the ACLU and I just
wanted to read this as I just want to
know if this if this is an opinion that
you would have or what or how you would
say we could address this um it says if
the state were to adopt this definition
government officials could likely
silence a range of protected speech
including criticism of the Israeli
government treatment of Palestinians
analogies liking Israel policies those
of Nazi Germany and it goes on to talk
about that um protected whether or not
we agree or not do you feel that that
that if this is adopted that that indeed
will um prohibit protests of somebody
that has a disagreement no absolutely
not uh I I think it's
a I think it's a it's a false claim and
and if you read the bill it it clearly
says this does not affect freedom of
speech that's number one number two the
definition itself doesn't even say that
criticism of Israel is anti-Semitic in
fact among Jewish people engaged with
Israel and among Israelis if you go and
visit Israel criticism of the government
is the national Pastime second only to
soccer um so it's not anti-semitic but
uh but the definition does point out
three ways uh that you can that you can
clarify when that criticism goes into
anti-Semitism and and those three are
are demonization saying Israel is
inherently evil double standards
applying different standards to Israel
than to other countries and uh um and
delegitimization saying that Israel
alone among all countries has no right
to exist Bless but bless um but even
still even recognizing that criticism
can cross the line into anti-Semitism
into Jew hate this bill doesn't doesn't
say that you can't do those things you
can you can say those things you can say
the most hateful things you can keep on
saying most hateful things but now if
you were to discriminate against someone
um in a way that's unlawful under the
laws of New Hampshire and you're saying
those things and you're discriminating
against Jews and someone wants to say
well why are you discriminating well we
can understand why you're discriminating
so um I hope that addresses that
question
yeah representative um as a sponsor I'm
not going to ask any questions but I am
going to ask representative wheeler to
re askk his question regarding um inata
and its meaning um would this bill would
this bill Outlaw the the word antifa or
make it or make it um anti-Semitism in
and of itself minus context because it's
an Arab War yeah mean that that was my
question to representative selig was uh
the word antifa used in a context I see
how that can be hateful but in another
context I mean that word means
revolution and I think how it's used as
important so would this ban the use of
the word antifa in that way uh then the
chairman asked my question for me
but yes Mr chairman representative
wheeler um this definition in this bill
wouldn't ban the use of any words it
wouldn't ban the use of that word but
let's also understand what the word
means revolution not not exactly the
first inata in 1987 resulted in 300 Jews
lynched or killed in Terror attacks
stonings lynchings uh and a couple of
thousand wounded injured the second
inata that started in 2000 resulted in
over 1100 Jews killed one of the the
most famous ones um which has
been which has been revived in public
Consciousness over the last few months
with uh on some of these campuses with
the bloody red hands where two Israeli
uh
reservists took a wrong turn into rala
and the mob took them lynched them
dismembered them um cut them up and then
stood in the window with bloody hands so
you've seen these bloody hand prints on
trees and rocks and at the Oscars on
some people's pins that's a called to
Lynch and and dismember Jews so it's a
very violent thing more recent uses of
the word inata was the knife stabbing
inata um the car ramming inata the
ticktock assault inata um I I've never
heard the word inata used in a way that
didn't call for a lynching and killing
and Terror attacks of
Jews thank you further questions oh
representative Newman
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my question um so I can see just
by reading the bill about the um doesn't
take away free speech because it has a
nothing in the subdivision shall be
construed as blah blah you go to page
two in the bill there are then several
other nothing in the subdivision shall
be deemed as doing this that and the
other thing could you is there one of
them that supports what you just said
about it this does not exclude the use
of the word in
in I couldn't even spell it so I
couldn't look it up in um it doesn't it
doesn't it doesn't create any speech
code at all nowhere in this bill is
there a speech
code people can say Jews intermarrying
is polluting our blood you know we've
seen that one around and uh and and Jews
are evil marxists bringing communism to
America and Jews are evil capitalists
bringing capitalism and all the
conspiracy theories and Jews control the
weather and Jews control the media um
none of that none of that is affected in
terms of free speech so the protesters
can can go with their signs saying all
their hateful things but if they then
stand at the at the gates of the campus
like they've been doing at UCLA like
they've been doing at Colombia and
saying if you're a Jew you can't pass
you can't go into the library you can't
come into the campus you can't go to
your class you can't oh if you're a
Jewish Professor you can't speak at our
school um then you're getting into
discrimination and if those people are
holding these signs and and you're
saying well I don't understand the
Discrimination this is all so confusing
here's a definition to help you
understand it are they stopped from
saying it no their their freedom of
speech is there but their freedom to
Breaking the Law unlawful acts is that's
not freedom of speech that's not first
amendment thank you
yeah questions um representative scitec
interrup M um this is uh not right on
the bill let me but I'd like to ask this
because of you're naal experience the
events of the
past months alarm me because is
anti-Semitism on the rise or is it just
being revealed what is your sense of
that if I may
ask yeah that's a that's a good question
um I think it's a I think it's
both I think there's a few there's a
there's a few streams uh going on here
um one the the attack of October 7th was
so bloody and
horrific
um 1,00 people killed
horrible genital mutilations of women
infanticide of babies in the most
horrible ways um Mass gang rapes of of
hundreds of women hostages taken many of
the ones who were returned came back
pregnant impregnated by their rapists
one of them
was tested with uh had 76 different DNA
specimens in her she had been gang rap
by 76 people and the people who hate
Jews already see these horrible things
and and it's like a mob mentality comes
out the victims down the victims being
pummeled the victims being beat up and
and cut
and and so they come out and they feel
they
feel allowed to say the things that
they've been keeping to
themselves I think that's a big part of
what's going on another thing that's
going on is there are people who have
been committed to demonizing and and
delegitimizing and destroying Israel for
years and these protests have created an
opportunity you notice at all these
campuses everyone has these matching
tents there's someone with a deep
pocketbook that's paying for all those
tents because if you ever go to a if you
ever go to a park or you ever go to a
concert and people bring their tents
everyone's tents is from a different
year a different decade a different
store they're different colors different
shapes and sizes but you look at
Columbia and you look at Yale and you
look at UCLA and they're all the exact
same
model um so you've got some people
funding and pushing it and you've got
professional agitators and
revolutionaries joining it because they
see it as a way to tear down the west
and they you know the the chant of uh
the chant of both Iran and and the huies
from Yemen is death to America death to
Israel and and among the houthis they
also add death to the
Jews um so that's another factor and
then and then a third Factor going into
this is you've got a lot of young people
in America um and at college campuses
and even at Ivy ivy league schools who
um who don't understand basic American
values and morals and uh and they were
raised thinking that that somehow
there's something good about being a
revolutionary well maybe when there's
oppression or tyranny
uh yeah but they're joining in because
they don't know any better so I mean
you've seen that too in in interviews of
these protesters where journalists come
and ask them tell me what you know about
Israel and Palestine when did you start
following this and and you'll see kids
say actually I don't know too much and
I'm just here because I I want to do the
right thing but I don't know who's who I
don't know what's I mean I see it in
frankly I've read the resolutions that
are being passed around and these are
organized through National organizations
and international organizations the
resolutions on college campuses about
colonialism and uh and and uh indigenous
rights and and you go through all of the
uh the Preamble and the whereases and
there's like a complete denial of even
Jewish identity and Jewish history and
they don't understand who Israel is they
don't understand who the players are at
all I mean Jews with a 4,000 year old
history in Israel uh 100 years ago at
the end of World War I there was a
movement to to to get rid of imperialism
and colonialism and create indigenous
rights and local rights and Israel uh
was created out of that a lot of people
look at 1948 the actual Independence but
it started in 1920 with the Sano
conference uh the Ottoman Empire gave up
uh a vast Empire and it was divvied up
to give Independence to indigenous
groups now you've got college kids
saying the Jews are somehow colonialists
because some of them lived in Morocco
and Algeria and Tunisia and Russia and
and uh and so they use this language of
colonialism when really it was a a
restoration of Jewish sovereignty that's
the language that was used by the League
of Nations a restoration of uh of
sovereignty for the indigenous people of
Israel and and uh
so so where's this anti-Semitism coming
from some of its some of its ignorance
and people getting on the bandwagon and
then and then there's also funding that
is good going you know right now um to
the Palestinian
Authority that's being funel to uh to
anti-semitic groups in America and
Europe to to push these narratives so
there is this there is
this you know this false narrative going
on kids don't even know they don't even
know who the players are much less who's
right and who's
wrong thank you for that um informed
answer and I suppose that would make
Catholic Bishops colonialists in uh in
the Vatican um representative
Muse thank you um in in our state we
have uh an enhanced penalty uh for
somebody who actually commits an act
which is found to be a hate crime um
what are you hoping that the adoption of
this definition achieves when it comes
to prosecution of crimes like that
so in in this particular bill I think
it's written just for anti-semitic
discrimination not for hate crimes but
um you could do that as well a number of
states have um and
uh you know once again if if the uh if
the definition is adopted for that
purpose it wouldn't be creating a new
class it wouldn't be creating a new law
it would just be about accurate
application of uh of the law in the case
of of anti-Semitic um acts criminal
acts thank you any further
questions seeing none thank you for
Testimony today so anyone else wishing
to testify on this bill who has not
turned in a pink card seeing none I
close public hearing again and we were
going to take 10 minutes and we will
come back to vote on this
bill
for
e
e e
with that I am opening the executive
session on Senate Bill 508 and I
recognize representative Muse to make a
motion regarding an
amendment thank you Mr chair uh this is
not the amendment we were just talking
about this is an amendment to the
original Bill uh that Senator Whitley
asked us to put in uh in the original
Bill one of the things uh that uh they
neglected to do was to include um uh uh
let me see what is the word the uh exact
wording for that uh I think it's
Certified Recovery workers uh as part of
the uh part of the scope of the bill so
that's what the amendment effectively
does uh and I ask you to support it
is there a second just second by
representative right
um that's correct the sponsor if
everyone recalls um at the end of her
testimony told us there was an amendment
because they forgot to add a group
that's all this is as a quick correction
any
discussion seeing none I would ask the
clerk to call the role in the adoption
of the amendment the motion is to
adopt here's a question if you
representative rhs yes representative
Pratt yes representative scitec yes
representative pu yes Representative
janen
no uh representative Manion yes
representative Reed yes representative
Stone yes representative tenar yes
representative Harriet gri yes
representative Muse
uh repes representative Duty yes
representative
Lane yes representative Murphy
yes representative Newman I'm sorry Ray
Newman yes representative Sue Newman
yes the clerk votes yes representative
selig yes representative uh wheeler
yay all right 19 and one the chair do I
get the vote oh
jeez chair Vol yes 20 20 the uh
amendment is adopted no it's 191 oh 19
excuse me 191 the amendment is adopted
um at this point I make a motion to
introduce amendment number 1645
H seconded by representative salig um uh
we don't need to discuss this unless
anyone wants to we we discussed it we
heard the hearing in the testimony what
representative wheeler apologies Mr
chairman I just wanted to say I'll be
voting for this amendment but I do have
some reservations that I'll be following
up on talking to the people who have
stakeholders about it and the ACLU who
issued opposition to it um I I am
concerned that we
sweepingly make criticism of the nation
of Israel um not the people of Israel
not the the Jews but the the nation of
Israel uh illegal under this and I I I I
do have concerns about that because um I
think you know we ALS I think most of us
here in this table support Israel's
right to exist but are concerned with
the current government and how it's
treating people in the Gaza Strip and I
think that's why how uh there's so much
concern in the in the country right now
about that um so yeah I just had to say
that I I I will vote for the amendment
right here I am concerned about
how it moves forward how broad it is I'm
I'm always concerned when we get an
amendment uh right beforehand but uh I
thank you for putting it together I
stand with the Jewish Community against
hate I stand with the Arab Community
against hate uh and I want to make sure
that we get a situation in which that
can work out so thank you for Miss
letting me thank you and I would point
out um just for the record this does not
Outlaw any language whatsoever it just
says this is a definition of a behavior
that when applied to an illegal act
would constitute a hate crime or
discrimination but the language itself
regardless of how it's put makes no law
no statements illegal um it just
provides a definition for
context um but I I
agree further
comments wow
um s508
yes we can one's a one's a non-gain
Amendment and one is the amendment to
the bill we've already adopted the
amendment to The
Bill thank you representative Stone
thank you Mr chair and I think the uh
efforts are apparently uh very well
thought out that we need to standardize
the uh definition and it's a prudent
measure that I fully
support thank you further represent
thank you Mr chair I just would say um I
appreciate your having brought this
forward and I would have loved to have
had the opportunity to co-sponsor it
with you initially and I'm happy to be
the second on it now oh yeah absolutely
and had I had more time myself I would
have included you in it um this was
brought to my attention fairly recently
and um I felt that it was very important
to get it in while we were all here so
that being said without further
discussion I would ask the clerk to call
the role the motion on the floor is
ought to pass as amend wait a minute
nope this is to adopt the amendment
another
amendment and I may just for for your
edification after this I may call for
another vote to merge the
Amendments because and I'm going to
check on that because I want to make
sure we're doing it right because
representative scitec has a point for
regarding two
amendments yeah but if we merge them
not so let's call the role now on
adoption of this amendment
representative rhods yes representative
Pratt yes representative
scitech representative Pro absolutely
representative janden yes representative
Manion yes representative Reed yes
representative Stone yes representative
tenar yes representative Harriet gri yes
representative Muse yes representative
Duty yes representative Lane yes yes
representative Murphy yes representative
Newman representative Ray Newman says
yes thank you representative uh
representative uh Sue Newman yes uh the
clerk votes yes representative cig yes
uh representative wheeler yay and the
chair chair V
yes right 20 20 Z the the amendment is
adopted I hear I make a motion to merge
amendments number 16
145h and 1781 H seconded by
representative Harry Gite um just really
quick for um parliamentary purposes um
we cannot have two amendments to one
bill therefore we're merging these so
that there's only one Amendment to the
bill comments questions concerns seeing
none I'd ask the clerk to call the role
on the adop on adopting the merging of
the amendments for that with ND
okay never mind um we don't have to vote
on a merge I'm just going to tell all us
to merge because we've already adopted
both amendments so the position is good
and those amendments are hereby adopted
and with that I hope you all have what
we have to vote as amended now I thought
we just did no nobody talk to me anymore
all right any further discussion see
none making the motion
um maintain radio silence is a I made
that motion I did I made that motion
right
okay call the rooll
quick yeah now it's
otpa yeah please get a
second Mr chairman
uh I read
the um fiscal note for Senate Bill 508
and it it raised the concern uh for me
and so I can't support the Senate bill
and I'll tell you why um this is uh
going to cause an indeterminable
increase in expenditures by the uh
counties and I'm going to read article
28a one more time the state shall not
mandate or assign any new expanded or
modified programs or responsibilities to
any political subdivision which the
county is in such a way as to
necessitate additional local
expenditures by the political
subdivision unless such programs or
responsibilities are fully funded by the
state or such programs or
responsibilities are approved by for
funding by a vote of the local
legislative body of the political
subdivision I will note that as a state
representative I am the legislative body
of the political subdivision of the
County uh we have had no such vote in
Rockingham County so I can't support the
to bill because of that fiscal note and
um exactly how much money is
indeterminate do you
know it's
unfund we don't know what I'm under the
impression from uh my friend Peter
lechman who serves with me in the
finance committee that indeterminant
usually means a small increase that
can't be Quantified yeah that's what I
thought too but that's fine you must
have just found out about this
representative
um with that call the rooll please
motion is off to
pass as amend as amended uh I know mind
representative rhs yes representative
Pratt yes representative scitec yes
representative PR yes representative
Janan
no representative Manion yes
representative Reed yes representative
Stone yes representative tenar yes
representative Harry uh Harriet G right
yeah representative Muse yes
representative Duty yes representative
Lane yes representative Murphy yes
representative Ray Newman
yes representative Su Newman
yes clerk votes yes representative
seelig yes representative wheeler yay 19
and0 or 19 and one
sorry chairman oh my God
done chair votes yes sorry filling in
I'm filling it motion carries 191 do you
object to consent representative
Jamon representative Jamon do you no
objection to consent we go on consent
with that I close the executive
session I do it every time you go back
to the
top
e
e e